dieser 24 februar ist ein furchtbarer
tag für die ukraine und ein düsterer tag
für europa mit dem militärischen angriff
auf die ukraine bricht die russische
regierung vor den augen der welt mit den
elementarsten regeln der internationalen
ordnung waschen stargate is not only
donnerstag it is not only you create
target ist es der politik
andere horn auf die international peace
oder
mein name ist gerhard genau ich bin
korrespondent der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung für die ukraine
polen und die baltischen länder und ich
sitze jetzt hier mit blick auf dem
majdan in kiew den platz der
unabhängigkeit hinter mir im fenster
[Musik]
heute 57 ich habe eigentlich einen guten
schlaf um 7 weckte mich eine sirene und
etwas später gab es dann eine durchsage
über öffentliche lautsprecher man möge
bitte bomben schutzräume aufsuchen ein
kollege meinte wie auch andere leute in
anderen teilen der stadt sie hätten
irgendwelche explosionen gehört es gibt
ja auch bilder dazu aber hier im
stadtzentrum selber habe ich das nicht
gesehen weniger leute auf den straßen
inzwischen auch weniger verkehr ich habe
kein militär gesehen die sozusagen auf
dem cent auf der zentralen straße hier
dem re-start ich auch kaum polizei und
auch ansonsten eher ratlosigkeit am
eingang zur metro die als bunkersystem
genutzt werden soll falls es so weit
kommt
das was die regierung versuchte über die
letzten drei monate dieses
bedrohungsszenario
zu verhindern eben gewisse panik
hamsterkäufe schlangen an den
tankstellen schlangen an den
bankautomaten ich habe so eine schlange
auch gesehen das hat jetzt natürlich
begonnen die banken haben auch ihre
ausgabe von geld etwas eingeschränkt
und die andere geschichte ist natürlich
männer aber auch manche frauen die sagen
wir lassen das nicht mit uns machen wir
greifen zur waffe
das ist auch so langsam erst angelaufen
in den letzten tagen wie viel das sein
wird wie viele leute das ist kann ich
nicht beurteilen
es gibt natürlich auch per fernsehen
also gerade wenn man nun in gefährlichen
situationen ist wie das so alles so
comic geschichten über den fernsehschirm
wie man sich verstecken soll was man
vermeiden soll dass man sich nicht neben
autos verstecken soll wahrscheinlich
weil die wenn sie getroffen werden
explodieren oder so etwas
aber sie meinen wahrscheinlich eher die
allgemeinen ratschläge die sind
natürlich ruhe bewahren er an seinem ort
bleiben was natürlich nicht verhindert
hat dass aus dieser drei millionen stadt
kiew nun lange autoschlangen im
schritttempo sich hinaus bewegen also
das ist eine dramatische situation für
diese stadt die sie natürlich seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg
auch nicht ansatzweise so erlebt
für mich ich werde nun so weit es geht
und soweit es sich mit meinen bewegungen
möglicherweise raus aus der stadt
verbinden lässt versuchen etwas
berichterstattung zu liefern aber wie es
mit der stadt weitergeht es könnte ja
das schlimmste szenario eintreten dass
tatsächlich die russen versuchen die
stadt insgesamt zu besetzen und dann
auch das regierungsviertel und am ende
den präsidenten und die minister
gefangen zu nehmen und also ein platz
brutal szenario wie es die sowjetunion
bei ihren verschiedenen ein märschen in
den ostblockstaaten also zum beispiel
tschechoslowakei 68 auch zuvor gemacht
hat
[Musik]